Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
had not yet been introduced at his
confirmation hearing when Democrats
employed a familiar protest tactic good
morning I welcome everyone to this
confirmation hearing on the nomination
of mr. Brett Kavanaugh mr. chairman to
serve as associate justice mr. chairman
before we proceed first in the 2020
candidates went Kamala Harris oh my
goodness despite the fact that the
Democrats were furnished with more
documents about Cavanaugh than the last
five Supreme Court nominees combined and
despite the fact that senators like
Richard Blumenthal have already gone on
the record as saying they're opposing
Cavanaugh's nomination well of course
they claimed it was all about needing
more documents
and mr. chairman we have been denied we
have been denied real access to the
documents we need to advisor Minh
regular orders cult which turns this
hearing into a charade and a mockery of
our norms was it funnier himself turning
into a mockery of course no episode of
the Trump resistance would be complete
without some of those protesters you
heard in the background and they were
going off like timed fireworks and a
tedious spectacle mr. Chairman I think
we ought to have this this loudmouth
removed I hope she's not a law student
there were 63 interruptions in the first
part of the hearing today seemed like it
was by 263 to me watching it and here's
what you need to know these were not
random events they were part of a
coordinated campaign of stunts directed
and staged beforehand by the Democrats
I'm reviewing a tweet from NBC that's
Democrats plaudit coordinated protest
strategy over the holiday weekend all
agreed to disrupt and protest the
hearing Chuck Schumer led a phone call
and committee members are executing now
this Chairman there was a phone
conference yesterday and I could tell
you at the time of the phone conference
many issues were raised one of the
issues was the fact that over a hundred
thousand documents related to judge
Cavanaugh have been characterized by the
chairman of the committee as committee
confidential
well it's good of Durbin to confirm what
we all know this 90-minute blue VA ssin
session at the top of the Cavanaugh
hearing was just clunky choreography it
was meant to fluster Republicans and
more importantly to mobilize the parties
left-wing base in other words it's all
about the midterms
they're not gonna defeat Cavanaugh he's
gonna get confirmed nay know it we know
it but the truth is
this is all the Democrats have there now
basically just the party of wacky
protests silly sideshows and goofy
stunts have no governing agenda or a
cogent argument they can't run against a
thriving economy or record low
unemployment or booming concernment the
consumer confidence so feigned outrage
is all they're left with one group of
leftist women outside the Cavanaugh
hearing actually dawned Handmaid's Tale
costumes as if the judges confirmation
of the High Court would turn women into
slaves of the state I know I looked
closely at it looked more like a high
school send-off of I don't know a little
house in the Prairie it was really
stupid gotta get a new costume
Department among the protesters
scattered through the hearing room was a
familiar face leftist activist and
professional rabble rouser Linda Sarsour
you'll remember she gave that very
understated talk at the Women's March
right after the inauguration
I will not respect an administration
that won an election on the backs of
Muslims and black people and
undocumented people and Mexicans and
people with disabilities and other backs
of women my dogs at home just hid under
the couch what's that I'm sorry a pause
over there but not only is the cast of
characters the same but so is the
general approach the circus at today's
hearing might only have involved so no
three or four dozen people something
like that but it was just as well
organized as the women's marches or any
of those spontaneous Pro amnesty marches
we saw earlier this year I call this
governance by stunt we don't have the
votes to change policy so we're gonna
win try intimidation after all we know
that most of the media are just gonna
lap it up so let's just let it rip and
this was the same play they used in
Chicago back in March 2016 when Trump
was scheduled to attend a rally at the
University of Illinois at Chicago
remember that Democratic congressman
luis Gutierrez moveon.org black lives
matter and other leftist groups organize
thousands of protesters to swarm
the venue there were scuffles and
violence the security threat was so
intense that the Trump campaign decided
to cancel the rally if you can't beat
him intimidate him
today's Cavanagh spectacle was revealing
and that it shows the Democrats enduring
rage over the election of 2016 they just
cannot get over it
and although Cavanaugh is supremely
qualified extremely well regarded as a
selection for the high court
he must be opposed because of the man
who nominated him who this absurd
political jockeying today by democratic
2020 hopefuls was as disruptive as it
frankly was embarrassing good morning I
welcome everyone to this confirmation
hearing on the nomination of mr. Brett
Kavanaugh mr. chairman to serve as
associate justice mr. chairman before we
proceed mr. chairman if I could just
respond arimin
if we could just respond to that I
wouldn't sir you can you can respond but
just a minute well that was Cory
Booker's voice he didn't see him there
but he was quite chatty today but for
all the chatter the Trump has coarsened
our conversation and Trump is upended
protocol what do you call that by the
way that went on and on and on I was
thinking about it today though you know
as they've done on college campuses and
so many other places walks of life today
the left is destroying civility and
sowing chaos they're doing it throughout
society as I think most of the rest of
America is just working they're too busy
for protests they have put food on the
table if this is how the Democrats
conduct themselves at what should be a
sober hearing for one of the most
important posts in the land imagine how
they'll govern should they gain a
majority in November and that's the
angle